hi i'm ria i'm a tasty producer i love
cooking i almost cook
every day i've seen a lot of baking
hacks around the internet lately
some seems very practical some seems a
little bit crazy
so today i'm going to try 30 cake hacks
in a raw
collected by my friend annie
i already made this and i'm going to use
this as a control cake
this cake is fluffy it's not dense it's
a very good
basic cake let's get started
hack number one in order to soften
butter faster
we can grate cold butter with cheese
grater
yeah i think it's already kind of soft
i'm gonna set this aside and see if this
works
so it has been 11 minutes yeah i think
butter is soft nice i think this has
summed up make your own baking powder
using baking soda
and cream of tartar how many people has
cream of tartar in your pantry
raise your hand if you're buying cream
of tartar
why not buy baking powder so i'm gonna
set this aside
use paper plate avoid splatter this is
kinda
become a guard oh okay
got it i already don't like this
we have to cream for five minutes
i have to kind of hold this paper
maybe if you're mixing whipped cream it
will help
okay let's take it off you absolutely
not need it
now we have a bunch of egg hacks test
the freshness of the egg
if the eggs is fresh it's going to sink
if the egg sits old it's going to flow
so we are going to
try the fresh one first fresh
this one's the older one
[Music]
it's also sunk it's meg if you wet your
finger with water
it's supposed to stick to your finger i
didn't get shot
okay so i'm gonna just put the shell
with your finger
excellent you can use this eggshell
scoop it out you could do it but you
also get bunch of
egg whites so when you separate eggs
you can use empty water bro and
stock almost
it's just broke we got fresh cold egg
come on in come on in yes
this doesn't work i don't think it's
called
hack everyone use so you just kinda
this works every time now i'm
incorporating egg
one by one if you don't have a
measurement
spoon you can just use cap let's see if
it's really
one teaspoon yeah
one teaspoon blow my mind
[Music]
i've used this tag all the time you may
saw it on eating your feed
you use parchment paper fold it
fold it again and again and again
see the middle of the pan and cut it
and you made the perfect circle that
fits in the pan
it really is cake very nicely i saved
this butter wrapper
and i can just use it here
because you don't need a lot of butter
just greasy a pan so this is like
perfect amount
next hack is cake release cake release
equal parts of shortening oil and
flour and make some sort of paste you
are going to brush it and
it will release the cake easily i don't
like showing
why not use just butter and flour this
is it
we will see after we bake the cake so
next heart is fabric strips
so these fabric strips supposed to
insulate heat and bake cake evenly
i'm going to bake the cake bake the cake
bake the cake take it out from the oven
next hack check the cake doneness just
touching cake
just like touch oh it's hot
if it's bounced back that means cake is
done
if it's not done once you press it it's
gonna
sink let's see the cake with this works
yeah it worked do you wanna see the
control cake
this also works cake really is hot
though
i wouldn't use it because you need extra
ingredients
cake strips i feel like it domed a
little bit
somehow it's brown so i'm not 100 sure
this only works in a certain kind of
cake
we made our own baking powder i think
cake rolls perfectly we are going to
slice
cake with dental frost i'm going to use
the ruler
place the toothpick evenly you're going
to
put the frost around it and you can cut
kick evenly
that was fun it's pretty even
look at that we are going to use simple
shop to
keep the cake moist i feel like this is
not even hot
this is something you actually do when
you're
baking cake i usually add rum
or brandy if you know me i like
to use alcohol in my cooking and baking
now i'm going to make butter frosting
another butter hack
you will need hot water warm up the
glass
dump the hot water flip it
so it has been 16 minutes it's still a
little hard to compare
room temperature butter it's not as soft
as
what it should be make your own powdered
sugar
you are going to need 2 cups of
granulated sugar
and corn starch
strawberry powder sugar looks much finer
than the one i made
storable powdered sugar melts in your
mouth much quicker
it's still a little bit grainy creme
core
crumb cork crumb crumb get into the
frosting so to prevent it you are going
to layer
frosting very thin put in a refrigerator
and
do a second coating so it looks much
more smoother
put a little bit frosting as a group so
cake doesn't move around
i bake two cakes so i'm going to make
four layer cake
[Music]
all right cake is nice and chilled
so i'm going to hold second layer and
finish decorating
chronicle works well i kind of knew it's
going to work
and the next hack heat up the spatula
to make smooth layer you're going to
just put hot water
so you're going to dip off the spatula
and wipe it
yes you're going to use this hack to
finish up your cake decoration there's
another hack
for make cake surface smooth which we
use
paper towel crochet against it
also make a smoother surface
do they work kind of earlier
so use hair dryer to make glossy finish
[Applause]
is there anything happening
i feel like nothing is happening so we
are going to start the decorating hack
use cookie cutter and sprinkle
for a cute decoration i put the cookie
cutter
and i'm going to add a sprinkle so it
makes perfect shape
i should have added less let's see
i put too much sprinkles so
it sort of works you can use toothpick
and write the letter first so you have a
guideline
i'm gonna write annie i'm not sure this
works
am i spreading your name right i hope so
am i a bad starbucks employee
it's kind of bunching up you can just
write skipping this step so you can make
simple piping bag
using parchment paper make
triangle and you kind of
make this shape twist it and make a
small hole
and add chocolate and you're gonna close
it
[Music]
honey next hug use
plastic bags as a piping bag cut the tip
put the piping tip twist it and put it
inside
put it in a cup so it's easy
let's try that it's working well
but there is a reusable bag i prefer to
use it
save the earth saves the turtle so
next hack is made chocolate topping
using
peeler i think it's longer it's better
it's kind of fun i feel like this cake
is already cute as it is i don't want to
put on top of it
i made it for you it's like the cake
from harry potter except prettier
oh i'm haggard you're my hagrid is it
the compliment
when you want to cut cleanly you can use
knife and hot water you're gonna dip
your knife wipe it
nice and smooth i recommend you to
use it another hack is cross
so if you're using this hack you have to
cut the cake all the way across
it's difficult to go all the way down
this is much bigger slice
[Music]
but you know the line is not
straight
[Music]
it's everywhere this last hug if you are
celebrating with a slice of cake what
you can do is you can use
a strawberry and stuff the candle into
the strawberry
put right next to it it's cute
thank you for coming along our journey
here are my three favorite hacks from
today
one grading butter hack two
cutting cake with the frost number three
using hot spatula
smoothing our cake
it's moist about white people doesn't
like moist
to let's not get into this okay
[Music]
you